TJ Holmes making news with another GMA
romance it's been a great week before
this one to keep going and going and
going just enjoy it days after his
relationship with co-host Amy robach was
revealed
et's learned he had an affair with a
producer on the Morning News show too we
will spare you America here's what we
know a source tells ET TJ was involved
with the producer for a few years who
also worked with Amy on the show but she
left GMA in late 2017.
ET has reached out to TJ the former
producer ABC and GMA for comment
good afternoon everybody Welcome to what
you need to know gma3 and it's Friday
Eve
who's looking forward to the weekend uh
me yeah yes when it comes to TJ and
Amy's romance which is Source tote ET
has been quote going on in secret for
quite some time the pair will not face
disciplinary action we're learning
because they are two consenting
co-workers who are equals there is no
issue with their relationship at work TJ
isn't that your favorite food
he always gets him in the holiday spirit
why do I tell you things in confidence
it's unclear when the love affair begin
but we do know Amy and her husband
Andrew shoe and TJ and his wife merely
fee big had split before the news broke
in nearly a decade prior to the reveal
of their romance TJ made his thoughts on
marriage very clear marriage gets a bad
rap a lot of times and I'm such a
marriage proponent I want everybody to
get married I think everybody should and
I think you're better off in doing so
fast forward to 2022 he may have changed
his views on the subject keeping the
romance alive in any relationship well
maybe it's a challenge these days just a
little bit sometimes right but looks
like the co-host's relationship is going
strong our source tells us the reality
is Amy and TJ have always had chemistry
so this match makes sense another tip is
to train with friends you set the agenda
you say here's number please
at least you feel the excitement of
doing it with someone you don't feel
alone adding Amy and TJ are both adults
who also happen to be in the public eye
so they're under a magnifying glass that
isn't particularly Fair they are both
together willingly and that's all that
should matter
foreign